vamos falar russo vamos lá vamos dizer
bom dia em russo a escrita aqui para mim
já não vai não vai dobre Ultra quê dobre
Ultra dobre Ultra dobre Ultra aqui eu já
me arrombo se eu tiver de carro na ru Se
eu precisar de informação para chegar em
algum lugar e eu parar em alguém e falar
bom dia pessoa dobre outra eu falei
obrigado e vou embora dobro na outra
esquina dobre Ultra dobre Ultra dobre
Ultra dobre Ultra vamos ver Boa tarde
Boa tarde dobrin dobrin gosta de dobrar
né do do medin agora tá até agora mais
fácil Vamos ver boa noite boa
noite meu Deus eu acho que eu fico mais
com boa tarde mesmo concluir aqui que se
eu fosse para rúsia eu ia acordar
meio-dia só dar boa tarde para todo
mundo que passasse e dormir de novo para
não precisar conversar com ninguém
pessoal passando eu dodinho doin doinho
começou a escurecer ficou de noite as
pessoas vão me dizendo boa noite eu fico
eu tenho até medo do que é que eu
respondo se eu escutar um negócio desse
no meio da rua eu digo vá você e me
respeite Eu não falo da sua mãe não se
filha da